nicolas sehnaoui bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
emmanuel macron a parlé d' un
gouvernement de mission déjà de quoi
s'agit-il
et quelles seront les missions du nouvel
exécutif libanais la mission que le
président m'a trop on suggère aux
libanais mais si on l'appuie
c'est de faire un gouvernement qui aura
objectif uniquement de se passer à que
je devais fort mais c 'est défendent
économique des forêts administratives
nécessaires pour que le liban puisse
avoir une gestion des marchés publics
qui continuent qui ne passait pas
continuer à se précipiter vers le bel
habit le président français a dit donc
avoir demandé la formation ce nouveau
gouvernement sous quinze jours est-ce
que vous pensez que ce sera possible
aussi rapidement
j'ai l'impression que nous avons c'est
que les forces politiques sont au
rendez-vous et que les que nous serons
capables de générer un nouveau
gouvernement dans les délais on parle
donc d'exigence 111 ingérence c'est en
tout cas ce qu'a déclaré le président
mais qu'en pensent les libanais qu'en
pensez vous et ce que vous vous trouvez
qu'il s'agit là d' ingérence que nous
demandait un gouvernement sous 15 jours
c'est normal pour toutes tout citoyen
d'impayés de ne pas aimer que des pays
même si ce sont des pays amis s'ingère
dans les affaires politiques cependant
il faut avouer que le l'évolution le 2-2
de l'effondrement économique et
politique que nous avons connue ces
derniers mois
on accueille si vous voulez de
positivement
l'intervention d'un pays ami
surtout que les la pression est en train
de s'exercer dans le bon sens c'est à
dire que
la france est en train de pousser à
l'adoption de réformes pour lesquelles
nous nous sommes battus depuis des
années je parle de mon groupe politique
et moi nous sommes battus depuis des
années pour que ces efforts soient
adoptées à le parlement et pas le
gouvernement
bon si la france nous aide à faire
passer ses réformes sans que nous sommes
au début de cette deuxième visite en un
mois des manuels macron il avait déclaré
qu'il s'agissait de la deuxième chance
de la dernière chance pour le système
libanais est ce que vous pensez
également que c'est le dernier moment où
le gouvernement va pouvoir réagir pour
satisfaire une population en colère
oui nous pensons que c'est la dernière
chance à cause du de l'afrique s'il
voulait de l'économie libanaise du
système financier libanais et qu'il peut
encore qui peut encore aller plus loin
c'est à dire que les chantres valait
encore beaucoup plus mal que ce que ce
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui et peut-être
que c'est cette dernière chance qui a
qui poussent certains partis politiques
certains go politique au liban king qui
les poussent à accepter ce qu'ils nient
ce qu'ils n'acceptaient pas depuis des
années donc laissé aux d'être positif et
de dire c'était cette crise l'intensité
de cette ville de quelque chose de moins
c'est qu'elle permettra un couche et
enfin de réformes et de mesures qui
semblent évidentes on parle aussi de
dernière chance parce que si les
réformes ne sont pas mises en place les
mécanismes des tca promis emmanuel
macron ne vont pas être activée ce que
ce serait un nouveau coup de grâce pour
le liban certainement que sans les aides
de la communauté que ce soit pour
l'explosion du pop ce soit pour
la dépression économique où
l'effondrement économique que nous
vivons
le liban sera plongée dans la vie une
dernière question quelle relation
le nouveau gouvernement aura t-il avec
le hezbollah
ça reste à voir
parce que ces règlements arrêté édicté
d'une manière claire dix ans par la
proposition du président français
mais ce qu'on comprend de ce qu'il a dit
c'est qu'il n'ya pas un refus de la
participation de la politique du
hezbollah et c'est la distinction le
président entre les politiques et les
militaires de même les américains ont
fait le même type de déclaration je n'ai
pas l'impression que que c'est ce point
qui qui fait il fait qu'ils bloquent ou
qui fait qu'ils posent problème bien
merci beaucoup nicolas sehnaoui je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien ministre
et député de beyrouth
merci